NBC Sports Boston Tom Curren here on the
Rich Eisen show how you doing Tommy hey
my friend how you doing I'm doing fine
figured I'd give you a call where did
the Josh Gordon news come from here Tom
were there any indications as to any any
problems that Gordon was having not
long-standing really rich you know I
he had one catch four on two targets for
19 yards the other day and you know I
was talking to someone yesterday and
they indicated that he's kind of was
starting to wall himself off a little
bit and withdraw but it wasn't as if
there was anything looming in terms of
this but it was attributed to look he
has a hard time in groups he was being
becoming much more silent and a little
withdrawn but that hasn't been going on
for weeks this was just something I had
a conversation with someone about
yesterday but again it didn't didn't
indicate that there was anything
sinister diabolical or of shoo about
drop so I guess then look that the
Patriots do a great job of keeping
things in-house as we all know is it
possible that they were surprised by
this blindsided if you will Tom well
what's really hard is and I spoke to a
friend of Mines sports psychologist and
he said we have to understand is these
guys are lonely lonely lonely and
especially with a guy like Josh Gordon
you come into a strange place you're in
spite dire financial straits you're
battling anxiety you're battling
substance abuse issues should have and
now the entire focus is on you so no
matter how much support the Patriots are
giving you you also know there's a quid
pro quo to it so there's an immense
amount of pressure but you're going back
to your rented place we have just a
temporary support group in place no
matter how much they want to hold you to
their bosom and you know that they're
supporting you in large part because
they lead you as an employee that he
made it 90 days when given what happened
in Cleveland you can tell that the
wounds are still pretty fresh he's
working
things are you honestly rich maybe I'm
naive I look at that as somewhat of a
victory for the kid and I don't look at
the Patriots you say hey told you so
shouldn't take it a risk on him I think
that they did him good you know yes you
bring him on in for the football but
while he's there you gave him a
structure that allowed him to play this
sport and find some organization for 90
days so to me yes that is that said
there's no way you can monitor what goes
on in somebody's skull or what their
cravings are or what their loneliness is
and in the end we're not even in the end
I don't know this is because it reached
critical mass for him where he said I am
NOT healthy right now and and Tom Curren
here NBC Sports Boston in the Honda
inside a report so that was gonna be my
next question I know this is very new
and fresh this is literally you and I
are talking about an hour hour death
after the tweet came out from Josh
Gordon that he was taking time off to
deal with his mental health are the
Patriots going to keep him in the fold I
mean are they going to keep him on the
roster I mean what what what will they
do here with two games I have a huge
regular-season just given the reports I
think was Tom Stella Sarah said that
there is a looming suspension which
would be indefinite and if that's the
case and if his move is reactive Josh
Gordon's too old I'm gonna step aside
before they tell me to or if it's
proactive and there is no ruling
suspension I think you have two
different things at what I would imagine
given that he's a restricted free agent
in the spring that they may stick with
him but I can't guess as to what the
tenor of the last week or ten days has
been because it's been outstanding
and he's a good player it's not what he
was in 2013 but I would imagine that
they're not going to turn him out into
the cold unless he came in with their
strong edicts of once Frank Josh so now
let's move to the football aspect of it
Tom since oh yeah that's the thing I'm
glad you did that because I think it is
important to at least articulate that
there's a guy there and I knew that you
would anyway but I came on the air
basically saying that this is a tragedy
this is I mean like and I understand
that tragedies involve you know multiple
fatalities in real life I'm talking
about in the sports world here okay that
um that this is for a 27 year old with a
god-given talent that he has and the
opportunity that he was given in the
world of the football would the yards
are so plentiful he stays he could have
been a multi-millionaire for years to
come and maybe he still is and that as
you point out as you point in your
column today is not the day to say I
told you so but in your column today
Josh Gordon leaving the Patriots hurts
on many different levels the football
level for a team that right now is
sitting in a log card position and we
all know that despite the monster
success of the Brady Belichick era the
ultimately successful seasons never
really come from a wild card round which
is what it looks like right now so what
does what does Gordon leaving right now
mean for this offense that was
struggling to score points in Pittsburgh
just this past week what does it mean
it's a huge whoa but if Josh Gordon was
becoming as Sunday may have been an
indication somewhat of a liability then
it least opens up the opportunity for
Phillip Dorsett and cordarrelle
Patterson now there's a reason Josh
Gordon was he was here in the first
place and that wasn't cuz this place his
father Flanagan's you know um for boys
it's because he's good and better than
Phillip Dorsett the cordarrelle
Patterson and Chris Hogan despite the
fact that he had to work through plenty
of things so they returned now to a team
that has Julian Edelman with a bad foot
and struggling to get the top speed
generally yeah Rob Gronkowski he's gonna
see more attention and I don't think
that he needs to see more attention now
from defenses he's having a hard enough
time getting open
Chris Hogue is fine as a compliment
seamless Phillip Dorsett and cordarrelle
Patterson she only had caught five
downfield passes all season prior to
about three weeks ago he's not a doubt
you'd only be targeted five times it's
not a downfield guy it's just not he's
not instinctive and he doesn't you know
he goes off route as they say here quite
frequently there's nobody sitting there
as a long snapper that can come out and
be wide receiver Tom there's nobody
lurking on untapped potential at the
whiteout there's nobody then but I don't
know I don't know man there's always you
know Troy brown clay corner I mean like
we all know what happens around these
parts man certainly when it's time for
playoffs please Tom please tell me
there's even a germ of truth in that and
that was come on no come on damn it
so you know what I mean
what do you think do you think that's
possible he is sitting at the crib right
now what do you think what's it hurt
it's a human isn't it amazing - that
Kelvin Benjamin was around - I mean that
would've been a guy that they could jump
on and obviously he's on the Chiefs
roster but in all seriousness though Tom
let me hit you on a couple of third-rail
subjects involving the Patriots Tom
Curren NBC Sports Boston is Brady hurt
no he's better now
okay the injury that he suffered against
Tennessee on the double pass we read
tweet dizzy
no Mike my former colleague good friend
and your NFL didn't work inside of my
shotty speculated that it might be an
MCL that MCL is he'll to the point where
he's off the injury list okay okay so
he's fine art all right he's not hurt
and Gronk is he at the end I mean is
this is this the end of Gronk okay no
yes
me yeah asking me what up what my
feeling is yes asking me to report that
with a bio line saying that I have a
source saying that no but he still is a
happy camper
what do you mean at all just isn't
having a good time last year we reported
on the fact that he's you know it's not
been an enjoyable season and this year
it's similar but different in that
health is again an issue for him whereas
it was not in 2017 so I feel a little
bit taken advantage of in the contract
stuff in the offseason the fact that
they gave him an incentive Laden
contract and now he's getting no prayer
of getting it he feels he's been
underpaid and taking advantage of it and
ain't a lot of fun so it's in his head
so in two hundred not his problems are
in his head but is you know this
productivity I think as every but
everybody's is often tied to how do you
feel about going to work right now not
great so 2019 Gronk is fill in the blank
we're sitting there saying should I
really have just stepped aside like this
because what's interesting is if he does
decide to retire for the Patriots
release him and he says I'm not gonna
play anywhere but except with Tom Brady
you know there will be a home for him
but I don't think he's gonna get more
money than he made now it's he's
entering a very difficult period I think
because his identity is tied to what
he's done and it's been compromised
it is only 29 so I could it's beyond
prediction really and then at what point
Tom looking over the steering wheel here
does the Brady future conversation come
up because there's been all that
conversation last year out of the Seth
Wickersham story and everything that
went down in the offseason pleading the
fifth and all that business got swept
under the rug or is in fact completely
evaporated I don't know you maybe maybe
you could fill in the blanks there but
what what about him went one
at that they've done a much better job
rich of coming today I guess done easy
troops 2017 was a season in which I
think no Tom was not really proactive in
telling the team number of different
things if he wanted to explore after he
won his fifth Super Bowl and I think
there was pushback from Bill Belichick
specifically and the rest of the coach
existe what's going on what are we doing
here this is not what we we've done it
in the past that led to the kind of
pissing contest between player and coach
that lasted throughout the season but
they're both not the most
confrontational people so they never got
it out aired out whether or not they got
it aired out necessarily I think they've
come to a truce and that both of us
could have done stuff differently and
they're in a better spot but I still
think that the evidence remains that
he's an older quarterback they have no
answer in house as a successor and while
what he is surrounded by and Josh Gordon
even being on the team is actually a
byproduct and a symptom of what he's
been so afraid he's been surrounded by
which was not that much you still have
to look at is he gonna make it to 45
he's entering the final year of his
contract do we want to read up with him
further or do we need to look to get to
somebody who can make the players around
him better by his own mobility in the
pocket cost less money so those are the
conversations that they're gonna have to
have once the final whistle sounds in
this confetti or not so wet when
February March April draft time what do
you think what does that come to a head
draft I'm okay or it depends on what
happens over the next few weeks - right
Tom I mean I would imagine yeah a lot of
it will just Tom want to come back Tom
looked at it the way he does josh
mcdaniels wanna come back who will Tom
be working with if Josh decides he wants
to take an opportunity elsewhere so is
work back I mean it's Julian Edelman
that this is that's why I wrote a few
weeks ago that there's a lot of bills
coming to play flowers is their best
offensive player in many ways he's a
free agent might make eighty million
dollars you know with the Patriots going
to match that they don't have any tight
end you know
ronk that's an issue they don't have
really any wide receivers that's an
issue
you got a 41 year old quarterback I'm
you may be a lot of bills are come and
do is that written Tom Curren a love
chat with you love your work love
everything that you bring to the table
when we when we have conversations like
this have a great Christmas and holiday
and I our season with your you and yours
alright thanks you go that's Tom Caron
at Tom Curren on Twitter follow him it's
great column Josh Gordon leaving the
Patriots hurts on many different levels
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience